ILYA GRIGORIK: Hello.
Welcome to our episode here
on structural and sampling
JavaScript profiling,
which, to be honest,
is a bit of a mouthful.
So thankfully, today, we have
John McCutchan, who's going to
help us make sense of it all.
So welcome, John.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Thank you.
ILYA GRIGORIK: A couple
questions before we get into
the meat of the conversation.
First is, what kind of stuff
do you do at Google?
And why are you the
person to tell us
about all of this work?
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: All right, so
I work on Native Client and
Dart in DevRel at Google,
focusing on mainly
performance.
And this is my background coming
from PlayStation, where
I spent five years doing
performance analysis and
optimization for games on the
PlayStation 3 and the
PlayStation Vita.
ILYA GRIGORIK: That
sounds awesome.
So I think you've already
partially answered my next
question, but what would
somebody take
away from these tools?
Why should they care about and
know about the difference
between a structural and
a sampling profiler?
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: So both tools
give you insight into what's
happening inside your program,
where the time is being spent,
and that's crucially important
when you're making an
interactive application that
you want to run and render
smoothly inside of Chrome.
ILYA GRIGORIK: All right,
fair enough.
So I think I'll kick off with
a quick overview, and I'll
just point out that, chances
are, you are familiar with
sampling and structural
profiling.
So structural is also
often called
instrumenting profiling.
And chances are, if you've ever
put in a manual timer--
like, here's my code, and I
want to time how much time
passes between these two
function calls or anything--
that is, in fact, structural
profiling.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yes.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Right, so that
is what we're talking about.
But there's also this other
approach, which is sampling,
which is something that
you guys have probably
used in our dev tools.
But there's a slight difference
between the two.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yes, there is.
I mean, the first difference
is just in their names.
Sampling is taking samples at
a fixed frequency, whereas
instrumenting, or structural
profiling, is measuring the
execution flow across time.
ILYA GRIGORIK: And
there's some good
pros and cons to both.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yes,
you need both.
You don't use one
or the other.
ILYA GRIGORIK: And I guess the
other takeaway for the
structural profiling is, as I
said earlier, chances are
you've done it yourself.
But chances are, you've logged
something to your console,
like a timer or something
else, whereas with
Chrome://tracing, we actually
have a tool that will allow
you to kind of introspect
and do better analysis.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: So instead of
just doing this structural or
instrumenting profiling, where
you're logging something to
the console, you can actually
do many nested structural or
instrumenting profiling runs and
have it outputted onto a
timeline track inside Chrome.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Yep, awesome.
So let's get right into
it and talk about--
I guess we'll start with the
differences, or explain what
the two approaches are.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: So with anything
that you're trying to
measure, it's important that
you understand exactly what
you're measuring and how that
is related to the bigger
problem that you're
trying to solve.
So a sampling profiler
works like this.
At a fixed frequency, your
JavaScript program is
instantaneously paused, and
the call stack is sampled.
So if we look at the code
snippet on the left of the
slide, you can see that the
program is calling foo, and
foo calls bar.
So the instant that the sample
comes in is maybe when the
program is inside bar.
As you can see here, the data
that comes out of the sample
is on the right side.
It's the call stack, which is
the hierarchy of function
calls at the moment that
the sample was taken.
ILYA GRIGORIK: So this is the
VM being paused right inside
of this function.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Exactly, yes.
So the VM pauses your program,
looks at which functions are
on the stack, and captures
this and
saves it into a buffer.
So you can see, exactly as you
can read from the code,
program calls foo and
foo calls bar.
And then that's when the sample
is taken, and so this
gets logged.
Another perspective that you
can look at a sampling CPU
profiler is that over time.
So here we have a timeline,
time running across the
x-axis, and a sample is taken.
And the call stack there
is represented with
a rainbow of colors.
And a millisecond ticks by, and
another sample is taken.
And again, another millisecond
goes by,
and a sample is taken.
A millisecond goes by.
Your program is paused
for an instant.
The call stack is captured,
and it's logged.
ILYA GRIGORIK: And the
millisecond is just a
hard-wired value within
the V8, right?
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yes, sampling
profilers can work on any
frequency, some at a very,
very high frequency.
Chrome's is at a reasonably high
frequency of 1,000 hertz,
or once per millisecond.
The issue with a sampling
profiler that I think a lot of
people don't appreciate is that
in between these samples,
you have no idea of what is
actually happening inside of
your program.
So you could very easily miss
or misreport a hot code path
that just happens
to be executing
off the sample interval.
You can kind of go
out of phase.
Your code can go out of phase
with how it's been sampled.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Of course, I
guess one of the assumptions
is if you sample long enough, or
if you make sure that your
workload is representative,
you should be
able to cache it.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yes,
absolutely.
So long as your workload is
uniform and representative of
what you're trying to measure,
if you sample over a long
enough period of time, the
timing data that you get out
of the sampling-based profiler
will approach that of reality.
What you miss, though, with the
sampling-based profiler is
that there's no sense of flow.
There's no sense of I was here,
and now I'm here, and
now I'm here because these
gaps are huge.
So once the samples are
collected, and the data has
been processed, what you get out
of it is two data points
per function that was observed
executing in your program
during the capture.
The first is what is called a
leaf of a call stack, and this
is the function that was at
the top of the stack.
It's marked in blue here, which
is bar, exactly like the
code snippet that we're
showing on the left.
Underneath of bar are
two other functions.
One is program, which is just
the main entry into the
JavaScript code, and the
one above that is foo.
These are what we call
inclusive functions.
So they're not leafs,
but they're
part of the call stack.
And so they're, in a sense,
executing, but they're not
doing the work.
The function that's doing the
work is the leaf, or the blue
function, in this case.
ILYA GRIGORIK: So this is a
nested call in here, so foo is
on the outside.
So when we pause it outside of
bar, that's my exclusive time?
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yes.
You're doing work in bar, but
foo is responsible for
triggering that.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Yeah,
makes sense.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: So on the other
hand, we have structural
CPU profilers, and what these
do is they record the entry
and exit times of every function
in your program.
So if we have the same program
here again, where foo gets
called and then foo makes a
nested call to bar, we have
our buffer, and we see, OK,
we've entered foo, so we're
going to record the timestamp
which we've entered foo.
We enter bar, so we record
that timestamp.
We leave bar, and so
we record the time
stamp of when we left.
And now, we've left foo, and
we're back at the program.
When this buffer is processed,
it gives us three data points
per function.
The first is inclusive time.
This is the actual amount of
time a function was executing
for, including time spent
inside if its children.
And then there's exclusive time,
and again, these are
analogous to exclusive and
inclusive samples.
But samples, again, don't
represent time.
So exclusive time is just the
time that the function was
executing, so it's the amount
of time it's executing minus
the amount of time that its
children were executing for.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Right.
So in this case, when you talk
about structural, the example
that you showed, you were
recording the entry and exit
points, which we'll just assume
that that somehow
magically happens.
So something has instrumented
our code to record this.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yes,
and we will get to
how that magic works.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Right, but I
guess the point here, before
we even get into how we
instrument our code to gather
the data, is that unlike the
sampling, here we are
recording every instance
of every call.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yes, you're
logging every call and return,
which happens at a much higher
frequency than 1,000 hertz.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Right, so I would
have the exact count of
how many times I've called foo
and bar, and I could even have
the time deltas for each one.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: You could
have the time deltas.
You could have the min, the max,
the standard deviation.
I mean, you could gather a lot
of statistics about what's
happening inside your program.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Which I think
also kind of hints at
something that we're going to
cover a little bit further,
which is there are different
costs to doing
this sort of profiling.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yes, because
the structural CP profiling
occurs at a much higher
frequency, there's just
naturally higher costs
associated with that.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Right.
OK, interesting.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: So yeah, just
in summary, we get the
inclusive time, which is time
spent inside of the function
and its children.
Exclusive is discounting
the time spent
inside of the children.
And then the call count,
which is exact.
So once you've found an area
of your program that is the
bottleneck, and you want to
improve it, the goal of
optimization is to minimize the
inclusive time of a function.
So that includes time spent
inside the children of the
function, which is just
intuitively what we all
understand optimization to be.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Although
something that you said at the
beginning, which is
once you've found
the function, right?
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Once
you've found, yes.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Right,
so how do we find?
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Well, we're
going to get into that.
We're going to discuss how
we can figure that out.
But of course, it involves
using a sampling and a
structural profiler.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Right.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: So the question
becomes, what do you use?
And the answer to that question
is you use both.
They're both very valuable tools
to have in your toolbox.
Of course, they both come with
their own pros and cons.
So as I've already touched on,
sampling doesn't actually give
you any measurement of time.
It's giving you a measurement
at an instant, whereas
structural or instrumenting
profiling, it's built around
the idea of measuring
slices of time.
So you get an exact measurement
of time.
[INAUDIBLE]
you can get an approximate
[INAUDIBLE], kind of attribute
a weight to every sample and
extrapolate to time.
Invocation can-- again, it's
approximate with sampling,
because it's only once every
millisecond that we're sampling.
So you could be called 1,000
times between those two points
in time and miss them.
With structural,
you get exact.
Something that you
were hinting at,
which is the overhead.
Sampling has a very,
very low overhead.
It's guaranteed.
Because it's at a fixed
frequency, your program is
paused, the call stack is
captured, and it's resumed.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Right,
so this is
specifically for a CPU overhead.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yes,
CPU overhead.
Whereas structural, because
it's at such a higher
frequency, the data being
collected in structural
profiling is cheaper
to compute.
It's cheaper to compute
the time than to
extract the call stack.
But the rate at which you're
doing that work is so much
higher with the structural
profiling.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Although even
that depends, because--
so in the example that you
showed earlier, we were
recording every entry to every
function, or every entry and
every exit.
But if I only care about one
specific piece of code, and I
just need an entry and exit
point, then if that's the only
thing I'm instrumenting, then
maybe that's not that bad to
begin with.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yeah,
absolutely.
In a manually instrumented
system, you can reduce and
minimize the overhead of
structural profiling
by moving it around.
ILYA GRIGORIK: And depending
on which mechanism you use,
you could end up in a scenario
where it could be, in fact,
incredibly expensive.
Then your code may
actually suffer
from an observer effect.
Just because you're looking
at it, when this--
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: It's
running slower.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Right, it's
exhibiting completely
different behaviors than
from what you're
seeing in the wild.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yeah, I mean
that's something that, just in
general with all optimization
and kind of measurement
techniques with programs, is
sometimes the very act of
measuring and observing the
state of your program impacts
not only the behavior
but the performance.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Those are always
fun ones to try out.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yeah,
how can you subtract
that from the data?
I don't know.
So overhead, very low sampling,
high to low with
structural, but you're in
control with structural
profiling, how high
that overhead is.
In terms of accuracy, it's
marked with asterisks.
It's a bit of a gray area.
It's hard to say which
one is more accurate.
I mean, sampling--
it's just measuring samples, so
it's incredibly accurate at
measuring samples.
But a lot of people have a
tendency to extract from
samples time, and that's where
it becomes very inaccurate.
ILYA GRIGORIK: And for
structural, if you're not
instrumenting the right thing,
then you may have missed the
actual picture.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yes, exactly.
ILYA GRIGORIK: And if you
instrument everything, then
you may actually suffer from
this observer effect, so it
really depends.
The answer is it always
depends for accuracy.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: And use both.
ILYA GRIGORIK: And use both.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: And iterate
and play with it.
So sampling has one added
benefit, which is that it
requires no modification
to your program.
You don't have to know anything
about the structure
of your program.
You don't have to know where a
good place to lay markers are,
and it just works.
You could go to any website,
run the sampling profiling,
and see where they're
spending their time.
ILYA GRIGORIK: So that's just a
service provider by the VM?
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yes.
ILYA GRIGORIK: We'll
pause you.
We'll take a snapshot.
We'll move on.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: While it is
possible for a VM to also
offer a structural and
instrumenting profiling as a
service, V8 does not.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Right,
right, so the
specifics of V8, actually.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yes.
So in summary, instrumenting
profilers give you very fine
control over like where and what
you're measuring, but it
requires that you have implicit
knowledge of the code base.
And you also have trouble
instrumenting things that you
haven't written.
If you have a library or a
system call that you're
making, you don't want to start
going in and laying
markers across it.
ILYA GRIGORIK: If I'm debugging
somebody's site, if
I just pulled that up, and it's
running kind of slow, and
I'm curious, I don't
have the ability to
instrument the code.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Correct.
It's kind of a non-starter.
ILYA GRIGORIK: So speaking
of which--
so I guess we should cover
very quickly the sampling
profiler first.
And the sampling profiler is
built into the Chrome dev
tools, so if you open up your
dev tools, head into Profiles,
you can click Start and
record a sample.
So actually, let's
do just that.
So we have the V8 Benchmark
Suite here, and I'm going to
refresh the page.
And it's actually running the
suite here, and I'm going to
start sampling.
So we'll let it run for
a couple of seconds.
We'll stop, and here is
the actual view of
the sampling profiler.
So Chrome was pausing the VM
once every millisecond,
capturing the stack trace,
and this is what
we're seeing here.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Absolutely.
ILYA GRIGORIK: And there's
no time sequence here.
You can't really see what
was executing when.
It's just showing you that, hey,
35% of the total time was
in this function called--
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: That's a leaf
function, too, actually.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Right, and you
don't really get that sense.
So you're familiar with some
of this code, and you can
figure that out.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yes.
Yeah, it's giving you, like,
35%, but what's really missing
from this is flow.
That's exactly it.
You don't know what led
to that computation.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Right.
So we do provide a little bit
of help in that regard.
So we can actually flip here
and look at the tree view,
which is going to reorganize
all the data in here.
And you can see that there's
some kind of
V8-specific stuff in here.
And then we can go to Run Step,
and we can navigate
basically down into this tree
and see what's being called,
kind of the call stack,
if you will.
But now, it's kind of hard to
figure out where is the actual
time being spent, really.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yeah, I mean,
you kind of have to fan and
drill into this large tree,
and then you find your hot
spot, maybe.
ILYA GRIGORIK: So the
tool is there.
It is useful, so another
tip that I'll
show is you can actually--
these trees can be very deep and
very hard to work with, so
you can actually focus on a
specific one and kind of
continue drilling down.
You can go back.
So this functionality's here.
The one thing that I really
like is you can load and
export these profiles,
as well.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yeah,
that's so important.
If you want to report a
performance problem to
someone, it's best to show up
with a capture in some way.
ILYA GRIGORIK: That's right,
don't just take a screenshot
and point an arrow.
I know I've done that.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: With the
screenshot, you end up giving
it to the developer.
And the developer's like, oh,
I really wish I could see
what's under that leaf, which
you didn't expand, and the
data's gone.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Exactly, so
export it, attach it to your
bug report, attach it to
your email, load it
later into dev tools.
Even if you just don't have the
time right now to analyze
it, you can save it and
come back to it later.
So that's a very brief
overview of--
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yeah, we're
going to go into a little bit
more detail about the
differences between these two
as the talk goes on.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Right.
So I mentioned some of these,
and I encourage you guys to
play with the V8 Benchmark
Suite.
It's a great place to kind of
get a really nice workload,
where you can see and figure
out what's going on.
Definitely play with the options
at the bottom, the
tools there.
It's good stuff.
And now, let's look at
Chrome://tracing.
I don't think many people
actually, first, know about
Chrome://tracing and ever
connected debugging, or
profiling, with
Chrome://tracing.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yeah, so
Chrome://tracing is a--
it's a hidden site built into
Chrome, like Chrome://memory
or about:GPU or something
like that.
When you navigate to Chrome
colon slash slash tracing, you
are presented with this
incredibly deep and detailed
view into the guts of what
Chrome is doing.
So it's kind of overwhelming
at first, you look at it,
you're like, holy--
I can't make heads or tails
of what this is.
And in sense, that's partially
because it's not really
designed for the end user
to be poking around.
But what you can do is you can
actually inject structural or
instrumenting profiling data
from your own JavaScript code
into the Chrome://tracing
view.
And so that gives you a really
interesting timeline view of
what your program is doing,
showing the flow across time.
But the added benefit is that it
actually frames it into the
larger Chrome context, which is
completely missing from the
sample-based profile.
ILYA GRIGORIK: The history
is also interesting, So
Chrome://tracing was built by
Chrome developers for Chrome
developers.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yes,
specifically for the GPU
developers who want to optimize
the low-level GPU
performance.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Right, so if
you're building a game, you're
trying to figure out what's
going on in my render stack
and all the rest, that's
definitely a tool that you
should be familiar with.
But I think in the process of
just using this tool, we've
kind of realized that there's
these accidental discoveries
of, like, well, if we instrument
our JavaScript
code, and we provide a way to
show that here, it allows some
very powerful debugging
capabilities.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Absolutely.
I mean, you can go in and
really have a deep
understanding of why your game's
running at 30 frames
per second rather than six.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Right.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: But so let's
step through this, but before
I do that, I just want to point
out that, while it is
very overwhelming, you can
really narrow this view down.
You can strip away all of
the cruft data that
isn't relevant to you.
So keep that in mind when you're
looking at it in the
first place.
ILYA GRIGORIK: We'll show
you some tips, actually,
a little bit later.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yeah.
So how do you use
Chrome://tracing?
The first thing you have to
do, which we've kind of
touched upon, is that you have
to instrument your code.
And the way you instrument
your code in order to
interface with Chrome://tracing
is by making
calls to console.time
and console.timeEnd.
You pass in a string parameter
representing the name of the
time period that you
want to measure.
So you can see here, we have
our trusty, simple example,
where foo gets called,
foo calls bar,
and bar does nothing.
And you can see that it's been
instrumented both at the entry
and exit points of
foo and bar.
This will allow us to understand
when foo begins
executing and when
it finishes, and
you can nest them.
This is a very important
concept, is that
it's not just one.
You could have as many nested
as you want, and
Chrome://tracing will make sense
of it and display it to
you in that hierarchy.
So there's lots of different
types of instrumentation.
We've kind of touched upon the
fact that you have to manually
instrument your code with V8
in order to interact with
Chrome://tracing.
But some systems--
I think Firefox's profiler
does automatic
instrumentation, so it's just
something to keep in mind,
that some tools will do this
automatically for you, both at
compile time and run time.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Yeah, so
actually, just before this, we
actually looked at Firefox,
at Firebug specifically.
And when you run Profile, when
you look at the output, it'll
actually tell you the exact
call count, which is
immediately a tip off that's
saying that it's
a structural profiler.
So it's much heavier, but it's
giving you a little bit of a
different view.
So keep in mind that these, the
way the profiling is done
in different browsers
is also different.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Oh, totally.
Yeah, I mean, they couldn't
be more different.
The Chrome Developer Tools
profiler is a sample-based
profiler, and the Firebug
profiler is
a structural profiler.
And it does automatic
instrumentation.
ILYA GRIGORIK: And it's not
a case of either one.
You really need both, which is
what I like about having
access to both here.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yeah,
it's great.
It's all on one hood here.
So you might wonder about what
are the costs of all of these
markers and instrumentation,
then?
We keep hinting that there
is a cost to it.
It's important to note that
when Chrome://tracing is
disabled and the developer
console is
closed, the cost is almost--
it's negligible.
You won't be able
to measure it.
It's OK to leave
them in there.
But when Chrome://tracing is on,
a cost starts to show up,
and it's about 0.01
milliseconds
measured on my machine.
So everyone's machine is going
to be slightly different.
But that allows me to do about
100 markers per millisecond.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Right.
Yeah, that makes sense.
Although, I'll still say that as
a best practice, you should
probably remove the
console.times from your
production code, anyway.
Even though it's basically inert
code, maybe on IE6 or
what have you, that may actually
throw an error
because it has no idea
what this is.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Absolutely.
ILYA GRIGORIK: So you should
probably strip it out, and
there's a couple of different
ways you could do that.
I mean, you could
try and do a--
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: What I do is I
have something called Push and
Pop, and you can just replace
the body of those functions
for your production
code with nothing.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Right, right, so
just wrap your own function
around the--
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yeah, wrap
console.time and
console.timeEnd.
Don't call them directly.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Sure, sure.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: So you have a
very simple one place to short
circuit all of that logic
and clear it out.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Alternatively,
if you're using something
like, let's say, Closure you
could actually build a filter
in there, so you could go in
and kind of strip it out.
Or it can be even more advanced,
something like a
[INAUDIBLE]
with a JavaScript parser could
actually get the AST, just
extract it, and rebuild it.
I mean, this is kind of going
into the crazy land, but--
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Well, yeah but
I mean, I think as JavaScript
applications become like that
big and that complex, these
sorts of tools will just
employed regularly.
So why not just apply
to this [INAUDIBLE]?
ILYA GRIGORIK: And I think it's
important to invest into
these kinds of tools for your
team, because you should have
this code in there, because it
makes everything so much
simpler to debug, monitor
over time, [INAUDIBLE].
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yeah, I mean if
you can find a way to leave
the code in there, like maybe
wrapped in some way so that,
hey, I've noticed something
going slow, why don't I just
click a button and get a really
good capture without
having to worry about going
in and laying out the
instrumentation again.
Yeah, I think best practice,
find a way to make sure that
that doesn't get called
in production.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Having your debug
data in production is
never a good thing.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yes.
So we've instrumented
the code.
We've added the calls to
console.time and timeEnd, and
now, we want to go over to
Chrome://tracing and start
recording a trace.
When you go there, it's going to
be essentially a blank page
except there'll be a toolbar
along the top with the Record
button there, indicated
with the red arrow.
Immediately after pressing
Record, you switch over to
your application.
It's important that you actually
interact with your
application while capturing
it, because Chrome will
throttle down your page
if it's not present.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Right,
background
pages get a lower priority.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yes, so you
want to be playing with it
exactly as a user would be.
After a while, you'll switch
back to the Chrome://tracing
tab and click the Stop
Tracing button there.
And as you can see, it indicates
how much of the
buffer you've used.
I don't know what the absolute
size of the buffer is, but
it's quite large.
ILYA GRIGORIK: It's quite large,
but the amount of data
that this actually collects
is ginormous.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yes,
it really is.
ILYA GRIGORIK: So don't be--
I've run most of my traces for
on the order of maybe 10
seconds, 20 seconds at most.
Right?
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: That's about
it, because the nice thing
about a structural profiling
is you only need one frame.
Assuming the frame is
representative of the average
frame, that's all the
data you need.
Where on the other side, a
sample-based profiler, the
longer you let it run, the more
it's going to approach
the reality of timings.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Right, so when
Chrome is actually tracing
this, it's actually storing all
this data in memory just
because it's so much data.
And I think we'll talk about it
later, but-- actually, we
have it in the screenshot here--
you can also export
this trace and then
load it up later.
So same story, you can
attach it to a bug
report, which is great.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Please do.
If you're going to file a
performance bug [? report, ?]
provide more data, because it
gives the developers the input
they need to solve
the problem.
If you just send a screenshot,
it's like, it's slow.
Well, you're probably right,
but how does that help the
developer solve the problem?
ILYA GRIGORIK: Right, perfect.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: All right, so
we've done a capture now, and
we see this.
Again, it's intimidating.
It's wild.
I don't know what half of this
stuff is, but that's great
because you can just
strip it away.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Right, so the
important thing to note here
is that this--
so Chrome://tracing does not
capture just your tab or the
page that you're on, which is
what the sampling profiler
does when you pull
up in dev tools.
This profiler will actually
record activity across every
single tab, every single
process, that Chrome is
managing, so this also means
things like I/O threads,
renderer threads, so each tab
has an instance of those.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: So within a
tab, you have the renderer
thread, which is where your
JavaScript code runs, and then
you have a compositor thread,
which does the interactions
with the GPU.
I mean, a given tab could have
multiple threads off of it.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Right, and so
for each tab that you have
open, you'll have each one of
these in here, which is what
the rows stand for.
So the first question is, well,
if I have a couple of
tabs open--
I guess first tip is
close all the tabs.
That'll make your
life simpler.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Well, actually,
that's a really
important thing to note for
any types of performance
measurement--
on a PC or Mac or any
type of computer--
is that if you have some other
applications, say you're
watching a YouTube video in
another tab or something like
that, that has an impact on the
execution of your program
and will kind of muddy
the waters
of what you're measuring.
So you want to close everything
down, keep it
really simple, not just within
Chrome but your entire OS.
ILYA GRIGORIK: It's your
lab environment.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Exactly, yeah,
you've got to keep it clean.
ILYA GRIGORIK: That's right.
OK, so how do I--
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yes.
ILYA GRIGORIK: filter some
of those [? noise? ?]
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: The first thing
that you want to do is
you want to figure out the
process ID for your page, and
the easiest way to do that is to
go to Chrome, colon, slash,
slash, memory.
And there'll be a table of
process IDs with tab names,
and you find the tab of
your application.
ILYA GRIGORIK: So you search
for your tab name there?
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yes, and then
right next to it is going to
be the process ID, and this is
going to allow you to filter
for the data that you're
interested in.
So we've already said the main
rows inside Chrome://tracing
are keyed off of the process IDs
that they're coming from.
So once you've gotten your
process ID, kill all of the
other rows.
ILYA GRIGORIK: So it's maybe a
little bit hard to see on the
presentation, but there's the
little X icon beside each of
the rows, so you can
just kill them.
So you know the process IDs, or
the PIDs, of the ones that
you're interested in, just
close all the rest.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yeah,
absolutely.
If it doesn't have your
process ID next to
it, get rid of it.
It's fine.
And then on top of that, after
having done that, you can
filter even further.
And since we're talking about
just profiling JavaScript
code, there's a Categories box
in the upper right corner of
Chrome://tracing, and by
clicking on that, you can
deselect all of the categories
of data that were captured
that is not relevant to what
you're trying to look at.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Right, so
if we're interested in
JavaScript, and we don't care
about the compositor thread,
you can just unclick
the renderer
and a few other things.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: So if you're
doing just JavaScript
profiling, you just want
to V8 and Webkit.
Everything else, turn it off.
So immediately, we've kind of
come down from that craziness
to something that's far more
reasonable, and you can reason
about what's being displayed
in front of you now.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Right.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: And then this
brings us to the awkwardness
of your first initial
interactions with
Chrome://tracing, which it
doesn't work as you'd expect,
where you can use the mouse and
drag around and scroll.
It operates based on the Quake
keys, so W and S zoom in and
zoom out, and A and D pan to
the left or to the right.
You can press a question key or
click the question mark box
in the upper right-hand corner,
which gives you all of
the other keyboard shortcuts.
But it's important to just keep
in mind that most of your
interactions are going to
be through the keyboard.
ILYA GRIGORIK: That's right.
You can, I guess, select
segments with your mouse, and
it'll show you a little summary
at the bottom as to
which functions are
being called.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yeah, it's kind
of like a lasso, and then
you get a lot of information
about what you've lassoed.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Right, but unless
you're panning left and
right and zooming in and out,
you're not really going to get
the high fidelity information
that's available.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yeah, I mean
you look at that initial
screenshot where it's just
craziness, you can just drill
in until each one of
those tiny little
bars fills the screen.
It kind of has an infinite
resolution there.
You just keep drilling.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Yeah, I think
you're literally looking at
nanosecond granularity
at certain points.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yeah,
it's really,
really, really precise.
So why don't we do a walkthrough
and do a profile
of some code with the
sample-based profiler and then
with the structural profiler,
so we can kind of compare
apples to oranges and see the
different types of data that
you can get from both.
So what we're looking at here is
a subset of the code that's
being executed.
We have a RequestAnimationFrame
function
called gameloop, and gameloop
calls A. A loops for two
milliseconds and then calls B.
And the body of B and C are not
shown here, but you can
see on the table on the
right how much time
they execute for.
So A calls B, and B executes
for eight milliseconds.
And then B calls C, and C
executes for one millisecond.
And then C calls D, which
executes for two milliseconds,
and you can see the body
of D on the slide.
It does nothing but that, and
then it just returns, and they
all return back up.
ILYA GRIGORIK: So it's just a
sequence of functions, A, B,
C, D, and each one does a little
bit of work and then
calls the next.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yeah, and
they're all nested.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Right, so the
total, one pass when we invoke
A, the total time would
be 13 milliseconds
once everything completes.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yeah, and so
looking at this table, you
would expect that B is the
dominant function.
B is taking 8 out of the 13,
so that's about 66% or so.
Yeah, so you would expect it.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Right, and we're
firing this, hopefully,
every 16 milliseconds,
which is why 13
milliseconds is important.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yes, if you
want to do an interactive
application using
RequestAnimationFrame, it's
important that you are operating
at 60 hertz, which
inverted, is 16 milliseconds.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Right, so to
render each of the frames, you
have about 16 milliseconds
in which you're
allowed to do your work.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yeah, and
we'll get into the real
details of that 16 milliseconds
later on, but
ballpark is 16 milliseconds.
So we'll switch open the Chrome
Developer's Tool and go
to the sample-based profiler and
run a sample of this loop
running endlessly for
a little while.
And then you'll see again,
here, a screenshot on the
right showing you that tree of
information, which we've
touched upon already.
But what's really interesting,
if you start to dig into it,
is you notice that the functions
A, B, and C are
actually gone.
They're nowhere in
this capture,
which is very unusual.
Doesn't make a lot of sense,
considering that B, for
example, is taking 66%
of our frame time.
It's not present in the
sample-based capture.
And also spinFor, which is that
leaf function which is
just doing all that spinning,
is actually showing up as a
very small contributor to the
overall execution time.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Right, so maybe
just to highlight, because I
think what you mentioned is very
important, so B is the
longest function, so 8
milliseconds here.
But as you're pointing out,
you just don't see it.
So for some reason, we see D,
which is supposedly two
milliseconds.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yeah, and D is
showing up, but B isn't.
That doesn't intuitively make
sense as to what you would
expect the execution flow of
your program to look like.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Right.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: So what has
happened here is through a
variety of optimizations--
in this case, specifically
inlining--
the functions A, B, and C and
spinFor have all been inlined
into gameloop.
So let me explain what
inlining is.
So inlining is a very common
compiler optimization.
And if you take a look at the
code on the left here, you can
see we have our variable x, and
we loop 10 times, and we
call A passing in x and passing
the result back out.
And all A does is double
the value of x.
It returns 2x out of it.
So a compiler will see this and
say, hey, you know what, A
is so short that I can just put
the body of A where the
call to A takes place.
And what this effectively does
is it erases A from the
program, because it no longer
exists by name.
The execution and the side
effects of its execution are
still present in your program.
The name of A is gone.
So the rule of thumb is that
the code at run time in V8
does not represent the
code that you wrote
in source code form.
So the side effect of this
is the call stacks won't
necessarily look like the ones
that you've analyzed.
ILYA GRIGORIK: And this is just
one optimization out of
dozens and dozens
that V8 does.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: And not only
that, V8 is constantly
analyzing your program and
looking for new optimizations
to test out and employ.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Right, so even
between runs, you might
actually have, basically, a
different representation of
the code in V8.
Functionally, it'll do the same
thing, or it ought to be
doing the same thing.
But what's actually living
inside of V8 may be very
different from what you have
in your mind when you're
thinking about that code,
because I am thinking of B
with eight milliseconds.
I'm trying to map it here.
I'm like, what is going on?
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Where
did it go, right?
And so in this specific case,
it was inlined and erased.
But I mean, yeah, V8 is
constantly testing out
optimizations.
It might take a look at a
function and be like, OK,
well, it's running at
this rate, now.
Let me try out this
optimization.
In a second, I'll see if
the new optimization
is better or not.
So it's just constantly
changing.
Eventually, it hits a steady
state, but especially at the
beginning, it's very volatile.
ILYA GRIGORIK: And not only
that, but this is Chrome.
These optimizations may be
different in other browsers,
or in other JavaScript
[? run times. ?]
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yes, Firefox's
optimizations will be
different than Safari's
optimizations, and they'll be
different than Chrome's
optimizations.
So there's no guarantee that
this type of optimization will
be employed in another
browser.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Yeah,
makes sense.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: So bottom line
here is that this trace just
doesn't really resemble the
application's real execution
flow or execution time.
Now, let's look at
the same program.
So again, it's A calling B
calling C calling D, but this
time, with a structural
profiler.
So we've instrumented our
functions with calls to
console.time and
console.timeEnd.
And keep in mind that these
functions, these calls to time
and timeEnd and the functions
A, B, C, and D,
can still be optimized.
They can be optimized however
the VM that you're running in
feels like optimizing them,
but the marking of time
regions will not be
optimized away.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Right, so we can
take the body of D, inline
it into the function above
it, and it'll take the
console.time.
Right?
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Exactly.
ILYA GRIGORIK: So even
though the code--
the shape changes--
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: We could be the
best compiler ever and the
best optimizer ever and inline
it all, but so long as we keep
the console.time and timeEnds
marking the regions of time
that we're interested in, the
structural profiler present in
Chrome://tracing will still
show us the flow of time.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Maybe one more
comment about this.
In the example so far, we've
always shown time and timeEnd
within the same function.
That doesn't have
to be the case.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Absolutely
not.
ILYA GRIGORIK: So I think this
is important to highlight.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: You can nest
them, and you can cross
function boundaries.
So what I like to do when I
first start off profiling and
optimizing code is start with
a huge ball of code.
Go from the beginning of your
frame to the end and just
measure that.
And then binary search
your way down.
So up above, you can see that
there is a timeline view here,
and it looks like an
inverted pyramid.
We have A along the top, and
then for less time, we have B,
and then for less time,
C, and furthermore.
If you were to actually get
out and measure this, you
could see that A is executing
exclusively for two
milliseconds, exactly as
we've instructed it.
It then calls B, which
executes for eight
milliseconds.
And then it calls C, which
executes for one exclusively.
Then it calls D, which executes
for two exclusively,
and then they all return up.
ILYA GRIGORIK: So this is a very
direct visual mapping of
that function [INAUDIBLE].
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: It matches
our intuition.
It's exactly what you'd
expect to be going--
ILYA GRIGORIK: And this is, in
fact, what you would see in
your Chrome://tracing if you
zoom in on this specific
execution of this trace, once
you're instrumented this.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: This is
a screenshot from
Chrome://tracing with
these exact
instrumentations in place.
What I find really interesting
is, it's hard to see in the
screenshot on the right-hand
side here, but you can see
that there's a little bit of
time from when D returns from
when C returns.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Yeah,
it's almost like a
pixel to the right.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yeah, yeah, but
that's exactly what you
would expect it to be, because
once D's returned, C is going
to execute for a few more
instructions and execute its
return statement, and
so on and so on.
The important thing here is
that the exclusive runtime
column matches exactly
what we've written
the code to run for.
And that was not the case with
sample-based profiling.
So in conclusion with this demo,
in this specific case--
and we've definitely picked
a worst-case scenario for
sample-based profiling--
it didn't present a very clear
picture of the program
execution flow or the time spent
inside a given function.
Contrast that with the
structural profiler, which
mirrored exactly what you'd
expect and the true flow and
time of the program's
execution.
But structural profiling
required that we, first,
instrument our code and then,
second, master the beast that
is Chrome://tracing to even be
able to look at this data.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Right, which kind
of leads me to believe
that you should probably
be using both.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Of
course, yeah.
Always start with sample-based
profiling.
So here's a walkthrough
of a real-world
workflow for profiling.
First step, of course, is you
just realized something's
running slow, or you're just a
very inquisitive person, which
is always good.
And then you run the
sample-based profiler, which
is going to highlight
the big target.
It's not going to provide the
precision and detail that we
saw with the structural-based
profiling, but it is going to
give you a landmark in
your code to start
instrumenting from.
ILYA GRIGORIK: And it's three
clicks, open dev tools,
Profiling, Start.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Couldn't
be easier.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Right,
and I'm there.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yeah, so once
you have that landmark, then
start laying out some of these
console.time and timeEnds to
kind of mark out regions
of execution.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Right, so it
could, in fact-- so I think
this is actually important
to highlight.
So with sampling, let's say
I'm calling a DOM API.
I can't really instrument the
DOM API in my structural code.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yes, although
you could actually
instrument around it.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Around it
and record it, right?
But the sampling profiler will
actually tell me immediately.
Like if I'm calling some
function which is blocking all
the time for whatever reason,
that'll show up there.
And then you can actually ask a
question like, OK, so maybe
I'm calling some expensive
function for CSS or for
JavaScript or what have you.
What is calling that?
What is causing that?
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: That's where the
sample starts to kind of
get a little like
Swiss cheese.
You can kind of see these holes
in it, and you're not
getting the clear picture.
And then you start instrumenting
around that
chunk of code.
You narrow it in.
But that's a great point.
The sample-based profiler
does show you system
calls that you make.
So if you call a canvas fill or
a canvas stroke method, or
you're modifying some property
of a DOM element which
requires a reflow, that's
going to show up in the
sample-based profiler.
So the key takeaway here is
that you start with the
sample-based profiler,
you then dig in with
instrumentation, and
you iterate.
This is not a one-pass.
You repeatedly go over this.
You're slowly building this
really detailed map of what
your program is doing.
So some closing tips.
Again, you start with the
sampling profiler.
You have to learn how to deal
with Chrome://tracing.
After maybe one or two attempts
at it, it's easy, but
the first time, it's
intimidating.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Yeah, I think
what I found very useful is
just finding a couple of good
traces and just kind of
wrapping your head around it.
So I think you'll show us a
quick demo at the end, which
will be very good to see.
But also just go into your
page, capture something,
scroll around, interact with
it, record a couple of
different ones, and just kind of
compare them side by side.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yeah, so some
interesting flow there if you
just want to figure out
what's going on,
is you want to find--
you could have a keyboard input
that will show up inside
Chrome://tracing when
a key was pressed.
And so if you go from there, you
can start following this
thread through Chrome://tracing.
It's like, OK, well, a key was
pressed, and the browser
noticed a key was pressed.
And then it notified my page,
and then my page ran my
OnKeyDown handler.
ILYA GRIGORIK: So there's
definitely a case of just
information overload
initially there.
And I guess the other thing that
I'll mention is-- and I
find this incredibly useful--
when you narrow in on that one,
let's say, input handler,
it'll actually give you
the Chrome name
from the source code.
So you can actually--
most of the time, you can just
copy that if you're really
curious about it, paste it
into your favorite search
engine, and you'll end up
looking at the Chrome source.
And I just find reading through
the comments very
enlightening sometimes.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yeah, I think
that's a great idea,
absolutely.
So part of this learning how
to deal with it is, again,
filtering down.
And remember, go to
Chrome://memory to get the
PID, and then just kill all the
rows that have nothing to
do with your page, because
they're just noise for what
we're looking at right now.
And we've kind of touched on a
lot of this here, but remember
that the time and timeEnd
pairs can cross function
boundaries.
They don't have to be within
a single function.
You could do huge reams of code
with just one time and
timeEnd and narrow in.
And the V8 optimizer and the
optimizers in Safari and
Firefox employ a variety of
optimization techniques, which
ultimately, to you, means that
the runtime representation of
your code will not necessarily
match your source code.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Yeah,
yeah, makes sense.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: And remember,
if you want to, you can
exchange these captures both
from Chrome://tracing and from
Chrome dev tools sample-based
profiler.
And it's a really great idea,
when you're interacting with
developers, to provide
them with a capture.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Yeah, so if
you're on the receiving end of
these things, start asking.
If you're currently
not getting these,
start asking for them.
And if you're the one filing the
bug, please include this.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: And just think,
if you go through your
library, and you add in an
optional instrumentation pass,
which someone who is running
into a performance problem,
you could just write back to
them set this flag, run it,
give me a capture, and
email it back to me.
So it reduces this back and
forth time between you and the
developer reporting the issue
to just one pass.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Yeah, yeah,
incredibly useful.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yes.
So another little tip that I
have here is think about the
data that's being processed.
Let's imagine a scenario where
you're iterating over elements
in a list, and you're doing
some computation on them.
Your intuition and your
expectation is that the cost
per element is uniform.
So cost for element one is the
same for two, same for three,
same for four.
So you'll lay out an
instrumentation marker that
says, well, I'm processing
my list.
ILYA GRIGORIK: So be creative
with your names.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yes, be very
creative with your names and
include them.
Because the instrumentation just
takes a string, you could
name all of your objects and
pass that string in.
So I'm doing work on data
item 1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
Oh, 6 is huge, as you can see in
the screenshot, which tells
you that maybe the data in 6
is maybe malformed, or it's
triggering a slow path.
ILYA GRIGORIK: So maybe I'm
processing a list of users.
I can just include the username
in here, and be like,
hey, it's data item 6, or data
John, it's taking a long--
like, why is John
taking so long?
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: And then you're
going to dig in, and
you're going to find
some really
obscure bug in your code.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Sure, sure,
or a megabyte of
extra text or something.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yeah, exactly,
or like maybe I've been
chatting a lot, and the log
has gotten huge, and your
algorithm that processes the log
is algorithmically slow.
ILYA GRIGORIK: So this is
important, I think, because
most of the time, your code
could be running just fine.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yeah,
it's that outlier.
ILYA GRIGORIK: It's
staying within--
but then every once in a while,
you get a dropped
frame, and you're just
scratching your head trying to
figure out what's going on.
That could be the problem, and
that's one way to help you
track it down.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yeah.
So budgeting--
like any good household,
you've got
to budget for money.
You need to budget for
performance as well, which in
terms of a game or an
interactive, very, very
responsive application, means
less than 16 milliseconds per
RequestAnimationFrame.
ILYA GRIGORIK: So let's,
yes, step back.
So we have 1,000 milliseconds
in a second.
We want 60 frames per second.
If you just divide those
numbers, we get roughly 16.6
repeated, so 16 milliseconds
to get 60 frames.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Right.
ILYA GRIGORIK: So that is my
budget to render each frame.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Exactly, you
have 16 milliseconds to do
everything, which includes
taking keyboard input, taking
mouse input, which actually
brings me to a
little side note here.
In your input process-- in your
OnKeyDown handlers, just
cue that up and process it in
your RequestAnimationFrame.
That's a much more
efficient way of
allowing Chrome to execute.
So that aside, you have 16
milliseconds, and you have to
do everything in it in order to
give Chrome enough time to
render your page at 60 hertz.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Right, and I
guess there's some overhead
for Chrome itself.
It's not just instant.
Right?
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yes, and we'll
highlight that in more detail
momentarily, actually.
But, yeah, it's really not 16.
It's actually, like, let's
round down to 14, maybe.
Depending on what you're doing,
it could be 13 and 12.
ILYA GRIGORIK: And actually,
not only that, but 16
milliseconds is also-- it's
not an absolute time.
I'm going to claim that it's
a relative time, because 16
milliseconds on this computer
that I have here is probably
very different from 16
milliseconds on my phone.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Absolutely
right, and then the same but
in the other direction with
your desktop machine.
16 milliseconds on this
might be 10 on a
desktop and 28 on a phone.
ILYA GRIGORIK: So if you're
optimizing your page, and
let's say you're taking 20
milliseconds to do the work,
and you've just managed
to get it under
14, and you're happy--
I mean, that's a great
one to begin with--
but I'm sorry, you should
probably get it down even
further to make sure that it's
silky smooth on mobile phones.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: We're all
developers, right?
So we've got these beefy
workstations with gigs and
gigs of RAM and 16 cores.
And you're like, oh, it's 16.
Awesome.
You get that on a MacBook
Air, it's not
going to run that well.
So the rule of thumb here is
always optimize for the lowest
common denominator of hardware
that your application is
expected to run on.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Right, so I'll
wave my hands and kind of
claim a rule of thumb, which is
to say if you're targeting
mobile phones as well, try and
stay under 10 milliseconds.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yeah, I think
that's probably fair.
ILYA GRIGORIK: I think that's
probably a safe-ish bound.
It's not a scientific measure,
but that's a good target.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yeah, I
would agree with that.
The lower you can go, the
better, but then the
expressiveness of
your application
goes down with that.
So you have to find that sweet
spot, and I would say 8 to 10
is a good rule of thumb.
But of course, with everything
when it comes to performance,
you have to measure, and you
have to prove that you're
still running at 60 hertz.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Perfect, so how
do we measure our hertz?
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: OK, so
that's going to bring
us to the next one.
So just summary here, budget and
then track the performance
across the project's lifespan.
Don't just measure one day and
then, the week before release,
measure again and be like,
oh, whoops, we're
completely out of budget.
Really break it down.
ILYA GRIGORIK: So I guess for
frames, we do have the
timeline view in dev tools.
We can hit Record, and it'll
actually tell you how long it
took to render each
frame, which is
actually very, very useful.
If you guys haven't
tried that, I
encourage you to try it.
But I guess you can also kind
of get a glimpse into that
through Chrome://tracing,
which is a
much lower level view.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yes, it's very
low level, but it's really
useful when you really want
to get down into the
nitty-gritty.
And by using the
instrumentation, you can
actually overlay your program's
real execution flow
with the larger Chrome context,
which allows you to
really see how you're fitting
into Chrome's frame, because
you're running within Chrome,
and you need to understand the
bigger picture.
So with that, why don't we try
out a little experiment here.
ILYA GRIGORIK: So I
think you want to
actually go to the Canary.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Here,
I'll let you--
ILYA GRIGORIK: Here we go, so
we just have a different
instance here.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: OK, just
a different instance.
So what we have here is a very
simple demo and some buttons
alongside here.
It's just a sphere that grows,
and then it shrinks.
ILYA GRIGORIK: OK.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: So when I press
this button here, it
runs at 60 hertz.
If I switch to 30, it's
hard to really see.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Yeah, I don't
really notice much difference.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yes, but I will
prove to you that it is,
in fact, running at 30 hertz.
But film runs at 24, so the
human eye is kind of
conditioned.
Anyways, when you drop to 15,
you really start to see it.
It's jerky.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Yeah, there's
definitely a drop there.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: And then
when you go to
eight, it's even worse.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Right.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: So why don't we
start at eight, and we'll
just run a Chrome trace?
So first thing is to figure out
our process ID, which in
this case, is 68139.
Then we go over to
Chrome://tracing, and we record.
We pop over here, and we just
let it run for a little while.
We come back.
We stop the trace.
So now, we want to find 68139.
I'm not going to collapse down
everything else just for--
ILYA GRIGORIK: So as we were
saying, there's a lot of stuff
on the screen.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yeah, I mean
just look at this.
Chrome DB thread, Chrome file
thread, lots of stuff.
But let's find where we live,
which is right here.
68139 CD render main, this
is the thread where your
JavaScript executes in.
68139 compositor, this is where
Chrome interacts with
the GPU on your behalf.
So you can see here, when we--
I'll select this region
right here.
I'm pressing the F key,
which zooms into
what you have selected.
And you can see that I've
instrumented the code, and
I've added a frame update
marker, and we're spending 132
milliseconds per frame.
ILYA GRIGORIK: So this is
console.time, timeEnd for the
frame update.
So that's you instrumenting
it.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: That is
me instrumenting it.
And you can see here that
WebView implementation colon
colon update animations, this
is where WebKit says, I'm
ready to call your
RequestAnimationFrame callback.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Interesting,
OK.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: So it's
kind of strange.
We actually have two different
pyramids here.
We have the first one here,
which is Run Task, Begin
Frame, Update Animations, V8
Call Function, and then
sitting on top but still within
the same thread, is our
own hierarchy of markers.
So it goes from Message Loop
down to V8 Call Function, and
then we start overlaying
our own.
So we have Frame Update here,
and I've added in AI Update,
which takes two milliseconds,
a Physics Update which takes
two, and then a Draw Scene which
is just artificially
taking a ridiculous
amount of time.
ILYA GRIGORIK: So this is a very
good visual way to get--
this allows me to very quickly
see which functions
are taking the most.
Without even analyzing
the numbers,
it's just very obvious.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yeah,
it's immediately
obvious in this case.
Draw Scene is our bottleneck.
ILYA GRIGORIK: So this is
for a frame, right?
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yes,
it's for a frame.
We're zoomed in, and
so next to--
oops, let me zoom out here.
I've lost my keyboard focus.
What happened there?
Sorry technical difficulties,
of course.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Probably easier
just to re-record it.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yes, I agree.
So here we go.
Here's another frame.
ILYA GRIGORIK: So stop, yeah.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: OK,
there we go.
Now, let's go down to 68139,
press that, zoom in.
So this is a frame update.
Next to it, we have
this right here.
And I know this just because I
spent enough time that when
I've lassoed that very tall
tower there, you can see here
that there is a call
to draw layers.
This is your clue that
this is where the
actual drawing occurs.
So the first thing is you find
your RequestAnimationFrame
frame, and then you find
this shape next to it.
And from there you can press
G. And what G does is it,
starting at the slice that you
have selected, lays out grids
at 16 millisecond intervals.
So you can see here that this is
the start of our frame, so
this is-- at this point,
we would be running 60.
At this point, it would be--
ILYA GRIGORIK: So ideally, we
should be seeing all of our
work fit into each one of
these small intervals.
That's your 60 FPS.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Exactly,
yeah, so--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: We've completely
blown our budget.
ILYA GRIGORIK: So how
many do we have?
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Let's see,
60, 30, and then--
15 or something, I don't know.
One, two, three, four, five--
ILYA GRIGORIK: So when we
recorded it, I think it was 15
frames per second.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yeah, maybe
8 or something like that.
We have about 8 times 16, and
we can see here that this
whole thing is taking
133 milliseconds.
ILYA GRIGORIK: OK, so we're just
getting less than 10 FPS.
So this is your eight frames.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yeah, because
you have 1,000 milliseconds,
and we're spending 133.
But I want to point out here
that, by clicking on the
message loop run task, it will
actually tell you the duration
of that slice, which
is very helpful.
You don't have to like--
we're sitting here counting grid
lines when we could have
just clicked.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Right,
but you know what?
So here's a question.
It seems we're taking all of
this time to just draw a
scene, but it seems
like it's not even
painting immediately either.
It's waiting a little bit,
and then it's painting.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: So let me take
another capture, which will
even better illustrate this.
So if we switch over to 30,
which looks pretty much
exactly like 60, but it's not.
Let me take a recording here, so
I'll just let it to do its
thing, and then I'll
stop the trace.
And again, the first thing you
do you find 68139, which is
down here, and then
you zoom in.
And you find that shape,
that same shape as--
ILYA GRIGORIK: So it's like
compositor thread, just
working with GPU.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Here we are at
our RequestAnimationFrame, and
if we click on that, we can see,
well, now our total frame
update time is about 15.3.
ILYA GRIGORIK: So
we're actually
just right under budget.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yes, and with
that, you would expect to be
running at 60.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Yeah, I am.
It's happening.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Let's see.
So I've gone ahead and I've
selected our tower of drawing,
and we lay down the
grid lines.
And you can see that, while
here's the previous draw here,
and if we measure it out from
one draw to the next draw on
the timeline--
ILYA GRIGORIK: It's taking
32 milliseconds.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: It's taking
ILYA GRIGORIK: So that's
a dropped frame.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Exactly, and
when you really drill into it,
you can see that, while our code
executed well within the
16 millisecond boundary,
Chrome's entire machinery
takes a little bit of time
to get it set up
to execute our code.
And then afterwards, in this
specific case, what it's doing
here is we've painted under
the canvas, and now it's
actually flushing the canvas.
So all of our paint
operations are now
being realized in memory.
Following that, we have
something called the commit
stage, and this is where Chrome
is signaling to the
compositor thread, take the
canvas pixels and upload them
to the GPU.
When commit is finished, it's
only at the next v-sync that
the draw will occur.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Right, so we
already passed our 16
millisecond boundary, so at this
point Chrome just says,
look, I'm just going to wait
until the end of next frame.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yeah, and that's
really what it is.
You are idle for, like, 14
milliseconds, doing nothing,
while Chrome is like,
I'm ready to paint.
Just tell me when the v-sync
hits, and I'll go.
So if we go back here, and we
click on 60, again my eyes
can't tell the difference,
but Chrome can.
So I've switched it to 60, and
I'll do a recording here.
I'll let it run.
I'll stop, and here we are down
at the render thread.
You start to get to know the
colors, so I've got my
message loop here.
So I find my draw call,
and it's not that one.
It's over here.
Here's a draw.
You can see Draw Layers.
So I pick that here, and I press
G, and I lay down my 16
millisecond grid.
So because my frame time
in total was only six
milliseconds this time, Chrome
was able to run my frame
update, do all of its
extra processing,
upload it to the GPU.
This is that commit phase again,
where it's realizing
the requested changes
I want the canvas,
uploading it to the GPU.
But that is all finished in--
well, we can click on
this right here.
ILYA GRIGORIK: About
seven milliseconds.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yeah,
ILYA GRIGORIK: So we're well
within our budget and, in
fact, coming back to your
earlier point about mobile and
different CPU and everything,
this is probably what you want
to see on your app if
you're targeting--
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: You've got
this nice space here.
That's great, because that means
that if you happen to be
running on a slower machine or
a machine that happens to be
bogged down, you've got room.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Right.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: What's
interesting here is this guy
right here is actually
a input handle.
It's a HandleMouseMove event.
So after the frame update,
Chrome noticed that I moved my
mouse and notified the thread
and said, hey, do any mouse
move processing you
have to do.
I have none, so it
just bubbles out.
ILYA GRIGORIK: So I think this
is a great highlight of--
this is a very low-level view.
You could correlate, I
press the keyboard--
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: And
this happens.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Right, or press a
key on my keyboard, and this
happened that kicked off this V8
function, which did a draw
call, and you can see
a pyramid, and
now I'm over budget.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Exactly, yeah.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Or
hopefully not.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: And you'll see
things like we saw with the 38
frames per second capture, which
even visually-- like, if
you asked me, is that running
at 60, I'd be
like, yeah, of course.
I know I'm under 60
milliseconds.
It looks as smooth.
I can't tell the difference, but
when you really drill in,
you can tell that you're,
in fact, not.
Your game update is at 60 hertz,
but the rendering is
delayed because you just
tip over that boundary.
ILYA GRIGORIK: So I think this
tool deserves at least several
more episodes down the road,
because I think it's very
interesting to look at
different tools.
So with that, let's
see if we have any
questions that we can answer.
And we have a few.
So the first one is, is it
possible to capture and export
this tracing data from outside
of Chrome, so if I want to
have it as part of Build Script
or something similar?
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yes, so
Chrome://tracing actually, as
its file format, uses
a JSON text file.
So you can synthesize your own
traces and upload them through
the Load button inside
Chrome://tracing from any
program, actually.
I've used it instrumenting my
Direct3D 11 game engine.
I've written out a stream
of JSON and then
just loaded it in.
ILYA GRIGORIK: This
reminds me.
We actually had an awesome
talk at Google I/O about
Android generating a trace,
which you can import, and it's
a Chrome://tracing--
so you export your debugging
your profiling data from your
Android device, import it
into Chrome, and use
Chrome://tracing
to analyze it.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: I think
Project Butter used it
extensively.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Yeah.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: So this,
I think, is the Android
profiler, as well.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Right,
very cool.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: And furthermore
to this point,
I've actually enabled--
so Chrome://tracing has an
open-source side project
called Trace-Viewer, and you
can just Google for Trace
hyphen Viewer and go there.
And what I've added to
Trace-Viewer is a support for
streaming over WebSockets.
So you could have a web
application hosting the
Chrome://tracing UI, connect
over WebSockets to some
server, and have the server
be streaming live.
ILYA GRIGORIK: So we're going
to have you back and talk
about just that, because I
think that's an awesome
application.
But I guess that one of the
highlights there is you can
actually take the
Chrome://tracing
stuff out of Chrome.
It's just a web app.
You just feed it data, so you
can embed it in your own
application, if you want.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Of course.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Yeah, awesome, So
next we have, "So sometimes
we made real time service
with long-polling.
It's very hard for me
to get a profile
result of loading time.
Do you have any suggestions
for these situations?"
So maybe I can take this one.
So Chrome://tracing may
not be the exact tool.
It may show you some network
data, but what you probably
want there is actually to use
navigation timing data, or
what's coming soon is
resource timing.
So I think--
I hope, fingers crossed-- this
will be in Chrome 25.
The idea there, that you'll be
able to extract all of the TCP
connection times, DNS times, and
all the other metadata--
as you can today for your main
page, the main resource page--
for every resource that you're
making a request against.
So you'll know exactly how long
that page is taking, why
it's taking so long,
et cetera.
So Chrome://tracing may not be
the exact tool that you're
looking for, but there are the
ways to get at that data.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Interesting.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Yeah.
"Can I use sampling to
benchmark my Chrome
extensions?"
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yeah, I think
you can, because from within a
Chrome extension, there's some
element associated with it.
Right?
ILYA GRIGORIK: Yeah.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: And then from
that element, you can bring up
the Chrome dev tools.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Yeah, so I
believe Chrome Extension just
basically runs in a background
tab, so you can open your
about:memory, find a PID,
and do the same thing.
So console.time, timeEnd,
and you should be--
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yeah, yeah,
you just put that in your
extension code.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Yeah, OK.
"Wouldn't it be interesting
if I not only used this to
improve my web app but also
to do a sort of regression
testing on my server?"
Yes, absolutely.
So I think this hints at
the automation piece.
So let's say we have this
profiling code, in--
well, it's there.
And as part of our build, we
actually log out some of this
data and somehow monitor it
and trigger alerts on it.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Of
course, right?
I mean, from within
Chrome://tracing, you can
export the data.
And when you export the data,
it's just a JSON file.
So you could write any set of
tools that you want that will
process this and put it into a
database and graph it for you.
ILYA GRIGORIK: So we were
talking about this just before
the show, but I don't think
there's a way to do that in a
completely automated manner,
like you can just tell Chrome,
dump into this file.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yeah, I mean,
it may be, but I'm not aware
of a way to do it, either,
although that's something I
would love to have.
ILYA GRIGORIK: So maybe that's
a future request, I guess.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yeah.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Do the time
and timeEnd have the
same matching name--
or do they have to have the
same matching name?
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yes.
So if you pass in time with foo,
you pass in timeEnd with
foo to mark the end of the
time region, although you
could have many nested
and kind of
overlapping time slices.
ILYA GRIGORIK: OK, perfect.
I think that's it.
So we're actually going to post
the slides, as well, on
the Google+ event page,
so take a look there.
And if you guys have any
follow-up questions, feel free
to ping either one
of us on Google+.
We'll be happy to answer
your questions.
Thanks.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]